and we're good okay so happy new year
everybody uh we are on with jen again to
get her status update jen how are you
doing i'm doing great thank you we're
really busy i'm at a coffee shop right
now can you hear me okay yeah i can hear
you what is this there's like room or
something behind you there yeah there's
like a closet i think it says mechanical
room it's like there's like a little
couch in the corner and i grabbed it so
i could you know feel like i have my own
little area here in the mechanical room
okay cool
i just finished a one-on-one hangout uh
at my condo and then ran here
uh to do this so for the people who are
watching who just watched the last one
uh i'm now at the office so the
background has changed
okay so it's been a while uh
december 12th was our last one i know it
doesn't seem like it's been that long i
think with the holidays it's just been
busy because i feel like i just talked
to you which is great
what's going on give me the update well
i just been super busy writing some copy
and uh um kind of based on our last
conversation kind of looking at more
ways to incorporate fantasy into my bio
and into
twitter updates and facebook updates and
that kind of thing so i've been doing a
lot of that and um and just writing a
lot of copy it's been great
so did you did you change your home page
um i did i did so on my yousomuch.com
website there's a new header on there i
still need to incorporate some copy but
um there's a new header on there that
says fantasy copywriter and underneath
that a new tagline that said words make
it real
words make it real okay you know what
i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go uh we're gonna screen share
this
all right
let's see
green show you so much
there we go can you see it
i can't see it
oh really when you see me oh there we go
now i see it
there we go you so much that's me there
you are okay fantasy copywriting words
make it real
and then what about the rest of this has
this been updated are you still going to
i still need to update that yeah
okay and the about or anything else
yeah i need to have the about the about
is actually okay i just think i need to
incorporate famous c into a little bit
more um so my home page i think i need
is where i really need to make most of
the jam
right okay
yeah it makes sense i mean i mean you do
see the use so much that the the fantasy
part is is kind of
small compared to everything else
right but if you keep doing it more you
know as part of everything you do then
they'll be easier to see
yes exactly
okay
let me turn there we go back to me
okay so what else
and um and then um i also did several
posts on twitter um using fantasy quotes
and that was kind of cool too because i
tried to do some searches too especially
with um some of the people that i follow
and that follow me and see if they ever
use fantasy um and it's funny because
most of the time when people use the
word fantasy they were using it for um
like fantasy sports football
um or they were using it for um
the fantasy novel genre so like a lot of
fantasy writers
yeah yeah okay yeah so it was great
though because i thought i didn't see
any copywriters using it at all so i
loved that it's a little unique to
copywriting so and i also did a search
on google too
um
and same things
i didn't really see it referred to in
any copywriting right
okay let's let's see your tweets hold on
i want to see something what did we say
did you see one a day what did we say
here we said one a week we said what a
week but i did i did a little bit more
than that one every one a week okay
that's right okay
how do i get to your twitter contact um
i'm at uh rockstar gen says
oh here is this it
yeah you can click on that twitter yeah
and i still have to change my twitter
handle we talked about that a little bit
but i haven't done it yet okay
but i did change my bio a little bit so
you can see it's a fancy copywriter on
there okay cool dream tele okay
and then
three two one happy new year
where is that okay when fantasy turns
you on your own
so you're putting quotes of other people
good okay oh you retweeted my stuff i
did it
it was good i liked that one yeah very
cool
i didn't escape from reality it's a way
of understanding so with these just
quotes that you found that spoke to you
is that what happened yeah exactly i
found quotes that spoke to me and i had
a couple people um retweet which was
kind of cool
and then i found other quotes the people
that were related like i think one of
them
i'm trying to remember one of them was
referring to dream instead of um
instead of fantasy but it was close
enough to kind of my philosophy that i i
retweeted a couple things that were you
know that were similar
cool okay yeah
um
what might help is if you find quotes
that you like
uh
if there's a picture version of it it'll
have a lot bigger impact than just the
report itself yeah
so like this one here
i wrote the quote
uh in the tweet
but then also included
okay has a much bigger lift so that
means there's not always a picture to go
with every quote but if you find
anything fantasy related that you like
that also has a picture with it uh those
tend to get a lot better response
okay
um
that's good and anytime i see a quote
that has believe in it i'll usually
switch this
here
i'll make that the hashtag okay so you
put it first okay
because what might happen if somebody
retweets you
and your fans is just at the end they
they may lose that hashtag in the tweet
because it's cut down or yeah you put
your name in there too
okay
um anyway little quick tricks for
twitter but this is good
i would love to see your own stuff too
right so not just quotes from other
people but uh
but this is definitely a good start this
is good this is good
okay guys okay let's flip back and it's
good that you're getting some response
who's uh who are the types of people who
are recruiting you
um i had a couple people from my um
actually spending at first it was
something i thought i didn't know but i
realized it was something from my uh
writing group had retweeted me
and somebody that i just didn't know
retweeted me too and i just um i started
following her okay yeah
good cool
it's starting it's starting
yeah it's good
uh so
domain name social media handles that
still
has to be done
yeah i still like you so much but i
think i'm gonna change my twitter handle
so it's it's it's
not rockstar jet it'll be more around
you so much i think or much
right because they have all these
different uh right too many different
ones yeah yeah
okay
uh
how is the chatting i mean i know it's
been hard with holidays and everything
but how how is the talk with local
business owners going
um you know honestly not not
not not much progress with the local
business owners because of the holidays
so um but i have been working on some
copy
just on the side kind of for them and um
want to show them soon and so maybe even
create a video around that which i was
going to ask you about because i know it
was one of my assignments for this week
was to um
you know create a video around some copy
i wrote for my aspirational client which
was the true and company lingerie
company
and i
didn't do it yet because i was like i
gotta ask evans his advice on this
because i feel like it's copyright so it
should probably have a lot of words on
the screen rather than just me talking
because i feel like it has more impact
when someone's reading it but the same
time i also feel like when i watch your
videos for example i think you have much
more impact when you're talking like i
feel like that your personality comes
through
you know it's really much more
engaging and dynamic
than just the words on screen you know
what i mean so i just kind of wanted to
kind of get your advice on this because
i know it's a little different and not
giving advice i'm sort of giving advice
but it's more it's copy related
right and and so the point of this is to
establish yourself as an expert i have
an ongoing series here that maybe you
help that client but in the process
you're helping a lot of other people
right
other business owners who might not be
able to afford a copywriter want to know
on their own or whatever right and so
that that
it's okay i think to read the copy that
is
that you've redesigned for them and to
read the copy that that the original
like the before and after yeah
before and after say here here's the
copy that they have now and here's what
i came up with
and when you're reading that you can
even have it up on the screen if you
want i don't know you know if you have
the
i wouldn't get so caught up in a video
editing
right prevents you from doing it even if
you're just reading it that's fine
the value i have here is you explaining
the problem
and your thought process and what
happened as a result
okay it's great to see the before and
after but
i want you to walk me through why the
before is wrong
and why the after is so much better
okay and that's come that you can you
can get an idea in your head but you
can't really script that it's not going
to be a solid if you're just reading
that out now that
you're reading something right yeah yeah
good
and if you're honestly sitting down and
you're
do you have like a do they have a
website or they have a flyer or
something that you you can get a hold of
yeah they have well they have a website
yeah is that what you're going to be
doing the copy for
their copy it's interesting because
their home page of their website their
copy is really good but then when you
click through to their products right
the product descriptions are what's
missing i think some good copy i mean
it's a it's okay it's descriptive of the
product but it's not it's not as fantasy
driven as
as it could be you know there's no story
there
um and so but their homepage copy is
awesome so it's really just and they
they change it up a lot which is awesome
too um but their product descriptions
are to me kind of boring so we're just
looking at the website and not the
not enough catalog or something like
that right
i don't even know if they do a catalog
that's a good question i'd be
interesting to find out um
because they do yeah i have a feeling
it's all online okay
um okay
so what i what would be great to see is
you going to their website
and clicking on a
a page right you can even use this
software through google right just like
i did a screen share
right you can create a hangout on your
own
hey it's jen i'm helping you know xyz
company and
talking for a while and then you should
you switch the screen share show their
website and what's wrong with it
and then come back to you talking and
then switch back to your word document
or whatever you wrote the copy in
so people can read along with you as
you're saying
okay
and then come back to you
and and round up
the video so
i don't want it's boring just to see the
kind of here's here's what it is and he
was like yeah i agree yeah that's some
context because a lot of the people
watching may not
fully understand everything that went
into it
right
right so talk about the process a little
bit too not just the reasoning behind it
yeah yeah yeah exactly
okay like it's showing that you like
you're very approachable you're
warm it's easy to relate to you
and if all you're doing is reading the
copy
right right absolutely you have a you
have a great personality that you don't
want
to hide so
um
yeah that's what i was i was struggling
with because i feel like that's with the
same with you like i feel like you're
very
your personality comes through in your
videos and if i was just reading off the
copy it'd be so boring so yeah i totally
agree
okay
good so when's that gonna happen
i'm for sure gonna do it this time no
really i am i appreciate your advice
that i feel like i have direction now so
um yeah i'll do that before our next
session
is the copy done
some of it is it's in process yeah yeah
and you're taking one
product description page and you're
blowing it up
yeah i'm thinking taking actually maybe
taking three products you know just to
show an example of how you know how you
can create a little story fantasy around
a product description to make it so much
more interesting
have you thought about the story that
you're going to tell beyond just before
and after with the text
no not until now but like i think your
idea of talking about why it's so much
more appealing um and going through the
process that i go through because when i
go through a product description i'm
looking at um you know like the actual
the details of the product itself you
know or the service depending on what it
is and descriptive words that you know
that relate to that and then create a
little story around that
and so i could talk about that and how i
go through that process and and then
they'll see why
you know how i got there i guess
essentially
okay so so to
um back it up and make it a little more
personal and more impactful for the
viewer
i would start with
doing a quick overview about yourself so
hey i'm jen i'm the fantasy copywriter i
believe
xyz
okay something
passionate just just to kick it off i
don't want like
five minutes of you
telling your story but just right
here's what i'm doing
and i thought it'd be fun to do this
review and show you guys
how you can make your copy more fantasy
related and have a great impact you know
on your audience right something like
that but you know put in your work
yeah and then tell me why you chose this
company
okay
right because you this is we wanted to
pick a company that you actually
potentially wanted to work with and you
like their products so
say like here's a great company that
i've bought from i love them they have a
great home page and three products i buy
from them
you know however many times what do they
sell again is it lingerie they say
lingerie yeah yeah and this isn't even
like hold up something that you bought
from them you know just
no i love that that's a great idea no
copywriter is going to do this right
this is what's going to bring them
uh and then you get into like here's
this you know it's got a great company
great product
and then you go to their website and
here is the description even if you have
like take the product that you're
holding up in your hand and show them
yeah
for that page that's a good idea i love
that how crappy it is
right and then you it made me now
reworking
all of your copy
that's okay you're right because i think
different i pick different products but
i love that idea because i could use i
know the products that i you know that i
own so yeah i love that
so
right if you can incorporate that
storytelling and draw people into you a
little bit more then it makes it much
more powerful than just the before and
after video
yeah
okay
yeah that's cool and then and then so
after you're done so i mean as you go
through it i guess so you have that
whole intro part
then as you're going through it you can
explain just like what you said explain
what's wrong with the current copy
explain the thought process explain you
know how you came up with the new one
that's more the technical
stuff
um and then wrap it up at the end so
like why this is all important
uh
what is like the key lesson that you're
taking from this
if maybe they're not writing enough or
maybe they're writing too factual or
whatever it is like sum it up for me
that i have a take-home
nugget that i can
use
um
what's gonna end up happening is you're
gonna have people who will will take
your stuff and try to apply to their
business themselves sure and that's
great like these are the people who will
may at some point aspire to hire a
copywriter like you so you're still
helping like a mass of people yeah but
you're also getting the people watching
who
love what you're saying and realize i
can never do this myself and i've been
trying to do it myself and every problem
she talked about that's me
right right
i need to hire her right so
um having that kind of sum up some
people will value their time
and and value expertise and bring people
in and those would be the people who
become your clients and others will just
use the information to make their
business a little bit better so you're
helping a range of people but also
hopefully eventually generating some
business for your company right
no i love that idea because you're right
it helps other people who can't hire a
copywriter or maybe just don't don't
need to like they just have like a small
amount of things that they need to
change on their own but then you're
right it shows other people who could
hire me what i can do
yeah and then if you had at the end
um
your logo or your website just an easy
way to for people to
get in touch with you
yeah
and i can emphasize the fantasy a little
more
yeah
fantasy yeah yeah
that's going to be part of the whole
video it's going to be part of your
intro
how you chose the company it's a
lingerie company right like that ties
into fantasy
yeah how you worked on the copy all of
that you know fantasy will be i mean you
can't
help but include
the 21 so
it's going to ooze out everything that
you do
cool i love it thank you
it's good i'm excited for that
um and then we'll see what happens with
that first video
yeah
i'm
hesitant to give you
more assignments
totally
we gotta kind of hammer these these ones
out
yeah i know i gotta finish i gotta
finish but i'm making good progress yeah
and keep doing keep doing the social
media stuff the twitter stuff i think uh
you will slowly develop a rhythm that
works for you
as you see people responding to you as
you see kind of what feels right so
it's okay to experiment with something
you know take a risk with something um
you can share some personal stuff on
with you
you know relate somehow
um but i would definitely start to
you know ramp that up a little bit at
least keep what you're doing and if you
can get it to
you know maybe one one quote per week
and one
gen thought per week
yeah i could do that
yeah
okay maybe even more than that
making notes
i'm making notes i'm gonna i'm gonna
have it and the next time we talk again
come on all this stuff
let's get going it's good it's good
this is good though i i it's great to
see
you um
embrace
the concept and feel comfortable in it
and i'm excited to see where things go
me too me too
i love it i know i have to admit when i
first talked to you last time i was
still a little tentative about the word
and now i'm like totally excited that's
great
no you know what it's different and it
takes time to sink in um i kind of went
through the same thing with believe when
i when i first
uh
took it on
i only said it to myself
yeah this feels right this feels right
and it became
everything um yeah
good okay any other thoughts or
questions from the past uh couple weeks
do you want to talk about
i don't think so i think i was really
really looking for some direction on the
video so i really appreciate that that's
great okay
okay
well hopefully
we can uh
watch the video on screen chair
and everybody watching can see too
and uh yeah see how it goes i will aim
to send it to you in advance so you can
look at it first and then you can screen
share with everybody can i look at it
first i don't know maybe i should watch
it without okay
okay okay
let's do this
let's see how i'm feeling
on the spot
i do too actually it's nice to see your
reaction so yeah i like that idea okay
okay cool
so you know two weeks here we go video's
gonna be done
okay
it's our my main assignment for the
weeks for the next two weeks so i think
i can do it
all right thanks jen good luck thank you
evan good to see you talk to you soon
all right